[Applaudissements]
viens voir les comédiens voir les
musiciens voir les magiciens qui arri
musiciens voir les magiciens qui
arrivent les comédiens ont installé leur
préteau ils onessé leur estrade tendu
des CALIC les comédiens ont les faours
ils ont donné la parade grand renfor de
tambour devant l'église Roulot pein
en cha
théâre et derrière eux comme un cortège
en folie il Dra tout le pays les
comédiens les comédiensir les musiciens
voir les magiciens qui arrive bien voir
les comédiens voir les Musici les
magiciens qui arriv si vous voulez voir
confondu les coquins dans une histoire
un peu triste tout s'arrange à la fin si
vous aimez voir trembler les amoureux la
mon sur ire avec les heureux pouchez la
toile et Entz dans vous installer sous
les étoiles le rideau va se lever quand
les trois courtiront dans la nuit ils
vont renître à la vie les comédiens les
comédiensire les musiciensire les
magiciens qui arri bien voire les
comédiens voire les musiciens les
magiciens qui arrivent les comédiens on
les mon trs il ont rade et plier les
calicot ils laisseront au fond du cœur
de chacun un peu de la sérénade et du
bonheur dans le mien demain matin quand
le soleil va se lever ils seront loin et
nous croirons avoir rêvé mais pour
l'instant ils traverse dans la nuit
d'autres villages ont dormi les
comédiens voir les comédiens les
musiciens
les AR bien les
comédiens
magiciens magiciens qui arrive
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien